so do either of you have any tips for
people at home who want to make
christmas queer
um
yeah question i just i just ordered a
rupaul um ornament um
and the sad part is i ordered not only
the real one but i also ordered a fake
one um that literally after i ordered it
i saw rupaul put on and was like do not
order this fake one and i was like
oh oh no
you've ordered the unofficial merch
i ordered both but i didn't know i
thought it was like i was trying to find
a whole thing of like queer icons or you
know um queer people to like put on my
tree um i'm trying to find ones of our
faces to put on there as well like i
want a little jonathan a little bobby a
little his hand on my christmas tree a
little answer
um and so yeah
i think the way that people can make
their christmas more uh queer in their
holiday season more queer
is by um finding people to help i think
that part of the lgbtqia legacy is about
bringing liberation and freedom to more
people and more awareness and more
equity to more people so like
reaching out giving to people in our
community i think that so many people
have had such a hard time especially in
the trans community
so many people are struggling and and so
i mean speaking of rupaul like so many
drag performers so many uh performers of
very
all sorts of different kinds have been
like impacted by this pandemic so much
so i think giving back and like helping
people would be a really fun way to make
your christmas more quierora
that child's gameplay too and i totally
was gonna say that dallas like i said
that but i was like no i'm gonna let
jonathan say it that's totally what i
was thinking
you two are incredible thank you so much
congrats on selling
and we'll talk to you soon